the other thing we were upset about is
that santino threatened to sue him for
naming this podcast
i wanted to talk about that good friend
did he wait wait hold on no we don't
have to bring that no we definitely
should
hold on when he came in i said dude i
love the show good friends
he goes oh yeah it's called scissor bros
i go nah i call it good friends he goes
i can't santino threatened to sue us we
called it good friends
but this is according to my brother
who's never told a lie what are you out
of your mind
what are you talking about man yeah
dude santino's upset that you guys play
on words there
see this is what happened because you
know that weak bert
tom drawing while you're talking okay
bert tom and um
my brother and santino they did that
they swapped podcasts right yeah
and so jeremiah was brilliant in the
fact that he was like oh we should do
one because it was april fool's week
right but also
the play on words your brother's show is
called bad friends you guys are nice in
them good friends make sense yeah but we
took
the logo we took their logo we took we
used the same
artist was there discussion first about
getting the logo or anything
it's his brother i agree look i agree i
just want to see if you even brought it
up was there a moment at the dinner
we're like hey please
i didn't deal with santino
jeremiah dealt with him and i didn't
deal with them but according to bob it
sounds like sounds like you got
you know bullied no he didn't bully him
oh you said bully outside and then he
said he threatened oh lord
to sue them if they use the name of good
friends
santino probably won't take the call
because he likes to duck confrontation
[Music]
um this could go terribly wrong that
that i don't know i just know that uh
and scissors what is it arts and crafts
show or something no i don't know how we
came up with the name but uh
we want with scissor bros and it's not
like
we just it's kind of just like a silly
podcast that we do
um at jeremiah's and uh yeah it's we're
only on episode three or four
it's like brand new you got to keep it
going now
yeah yeah keep it as good friends dude
yeah
to pipe down nobody owns the trademark
on
the name friends you can't yeah trust me
i do have trademarks all the time
you can't own the name i heard there's a
parody law as well would you say
a parody correct that's how barstool can
play like they can make tom brady shirts
michael rapport shirts like
if you do a parody you can get away with
it oh lord
so uh yeah i didn't want to ruffle any
feathers so we just kind of like let it
be you know jeremiah dealt with him yes
back down
and we just said all right no it was
just a gag we're going to change to the
name
and that's why how upset was he
according to bob he said he hadn't seen
him that mad in his life oh wow
but now according to bob also which was
a bad which was actually a good movie
when i was growing up with bill simmons
in it
yeah will you tell me this though the
did you ever discuss it with your
brother
and be honest with me wait what are you
talking about like did you run it past
bobby when you're playing video games
like hey dude means you're minding your
new podcast
that wouldn't be fun no no it was a
surprise it was because we we wanted to
um
surprise them yeah the surprise element
you can't surprise someone who's a theft
i don't feel like
he's a [ __ ] target and uh it's just a
but it's his brother yeah
he's good friends yeah and he's not
taken away from their show
yeah and so yeah we just let it go and
then
like i didn't you know i didn't i mean
if if he's getting that upset
about something that we were just joking
around about and so what is it now is it
scissor bros good friend
it's no it's just uh see uh so jeremiah
called him just to say hey we understand
we just it was a joke can we just at
least
for our episode two can we still use the
logo
but cross it out just for branding
purposes to let people know
hey now it was a gag and now it's this
is the legit name
scissor bros and he was cool with that
yeah but he was he wanted to make sure
you you know you're not going to use
are you guys under their network or
something or do they help with yourself
no no we
no i don't know i said to you and bobby
just so like yeah come on our network
good friends bad friends help build
grow this thing yeah like if you wanted
to be watching what friends do
yeah i never thought of it that way so
their show should just be called bad
or just or just yeah just [ __ ] well
but i'm sure when they see this
um they're not going to be too happy
with the drawing
well the drawing's not too good look at
the drawing okay you're drawing the
nightstalker
[Music]